el gigante de los pesticidas y semillas
transgénicas bayern perdió una batalla
en mexico el regulador sanitario del
país la cofepris rechazó un permiso para
una nueva variedad de maíz transgénico
solicitada por esa empresa farmacéutica
alemana se negó el primer permiso de
importación de las nuevas variedades de
semillas llamo a bayern el regulador
determinó que la nueva variedad de
semilla estaba diseñada para tolerar el
herbicida glifosato una sustancia que
considera peligrosa por lo tanto dijo
que su rechazo se basaba en un principio
de precaución creo que aquí es una
especie de rescate cultural de nuestras
raíces de nuestra identidad porque al
final es de bueno no se ha probado pero
los seres humanos somos lo que nos
comemos la gigante farmacéutica bayer
declaró este viernes que está evaluando
sus opciones legales criticando la
decisión común o científica creo que es
un tema muy delicado que estamos dejando
que la ideología
o sea la que está detrás de la toma de
decisiones y va a ser un error
monumental
méxico cuna del maíz moderno nunca
permitió el cultivo escala comercial de
maíz transgénico pero durante décadas
gozó de la importación de estas
variedades aprobando unas 90 especies
modificadas pero bajo el gobierno del
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
quien asumió el cargo a finales de 2018
la cofepris no aprobó ninguna semilla
transgénica